president Trump pressuring Democrats to
return to Washington to help millions of
suffering Americans House Democrats say
a congressional physician warned it
could be dangerous to return to work but
President Trump has a different theory
Democrats they don't want to come back
they don't want to come back I think
they should be back here but they don't
they're enjoying their vacation and they
shouldn't be Nancy Pelosi eating ice
cream on late-night television so
Kennedy it's I think you know pretty
safe ground to make fun of Democrats for
not wanting to come back as a lot of
people think that Congress doesn't do
anything anyway so there's that but what
about this point that the Democrats say
that their doctor told them that it
would not be a good idea I mean how do
they way that they socially distance
they wear face masks they wash their
hands so they don't touch their face and
they come back and they do critical work
because their work decides who lives and
dies right now and that is the
unfortunate reality you know it's very
easy for them to stay in quarantine and
you know for the most part by and large
their gilded towers and expect people to
work in nursing homes and hospitals and
fire and police stations and Chipotle
Kentucky congressman Thomas Massie has
been very entertaining on this he wants
to get back to work he's challenging
people to get back to work House
Democrats say they don't have any
legislation so why should they hurry
back to craft legislation and at least
do something to make the situation
better and make your constituents feel
like you care about them well one one of
the things that they could do is
Senators Portman and Durbin in a
bipartisan way have proposed a way for
the senators and the Congress to be able
to vote either by proxy or you know from
afar and there's so much resistance to
that I mean doesn't there seem like
there's a technological solution here I
think there is I mean it's pretty clear
what you just laid out Dana that's
exactly right but you know there's a lot
of tradition about people showing up in
person in the Congress to do the work
you know what we're talking about though
is a 4.8 shrinkage in terms of gee
gross domestic product over the next the
last quarter that's terrible and I don't
think you can blame Republicans or
Democrats and I sure don't think anybody
can do anything but blame the virus
let's just be clear and when it comes to
the Congress and the the president's
nasty little comment about ice cream and
they're enjoying their vacation I don't
understand because Democrats in fact
with Republicans have passed four large
bills two of them with huge spending
intended to deal with this issue and the
Democrats worked very hard to the point
that some Republicans said oh you're
slowing it down by making these demands
and these demands aren't directly
related but the Democrats are working to
get in money for hospitals for people
who are poor and hungry in this country
right I think you can even if you are a
hard-line or make a case with them so I
don't think that's a fair argument and I
think that I would agree with candy on
people coming back I think that if you
can get one or two staffers in there go
to work and Greg they already know that
they're gonna have to do more going
forward and members of Congress need to
be that I mean they haven't had any
committee meetings they can't do any of
the work even if they wanted to do
oversight they couldn't do that so your
thoughts
oh god this is hard because I don't want
them to work you know because I just
don't want them to work however you know
the founding fathers assumed because you
know that I am an expert on to the
founding fathers that people had to be
present in the Capitol to work but
there's a few things that have happened
since then there are these things called
computers and you can get on the
internet and you can do stuff from afar
I just ordered like a hundred bucks
worth of Records I think I think you
know these guys and they're old and
they're fat and they're unhealthy stay
home and work from home and you can pass
all this money from there I think it's
time that we change these traditions to
reflect the reality that there is and
and and I agree with one you know the
economy is four point what's at 4.8% the
argument that this is an evil
capitalist society which is often
propagated on our American campuses by
professors who read nothing but Noam
Chomsky and Howard Zinn they claim that
this is an evil greedy Society how is it
that this evil greedy society
sacrificing its economy to save the most
vulnerable people I mean even Sweden you
know the model of of cool socialism
didn't even do that but here that cat
America is doing something so incredible
it's so incredible and we tend to forget
that and I think we need to remind
ourselves of that maybe Jessie do you
think that these members of Congress
need to get back to town I do
do you remember during the shutdown when
Nancy tried to leave the country on a
jet and the president grounded the jet I
think this time he should send a jet to
Nancy stock it full of ice cream and say
in five we're going wheels up Nance and
I'm gonna give you a lift back to DC I
mean she's like the most powerful woman
in the world and she's sitting at hiding
in her mansion you can't say the
president's not leading and then hide in
your mansion it's not a good look
especially when the Senate's coming back
to work she's basically acknowledging
she's not an essential employee and most
of the time congressmen aren't but now
they are she could go back and do China
she could do infrastructure she could do
testing she could create tons of
legislation so it would be a symbolic
move to show the Congress working again
they should be on the front lines along
everybody else
I just hope Nancy doesn't want to stay
at home because she doesn't want to help
the recovery or visually associate
herself with the federal government
response but I'm gonna give her the
benefit of the doubt I'm sure you hope
that I